das hier ist das dritte Video der
siebenteiligen Interviewserie mit den
Teilnehmern von Seven vs world Staffel 2
viel Spaß mit dem Interview von Fritz
ja der größte Unterschied Teilnehmer
technisch von Staffel 1 zu Staffel 2 war
auf jeden Fall in der ersten Staffel in
Schweden waren halt alles irgendwie
Kumpels die aus dem Autobereich kommen
und in der zweiten Staffel war es ein
kompletter Mix wirklich von jemandem der
krass für Erfahrung hat wie ein Otto mit
verschiedensten militärischen Lehrgängen
bis zu hin genauso wieder gar keine
Erfahrung hat und paar Leuten dazwischen
das war die Besonderheit also viel
buntere Mischung ein Staffel 2 hat sich
einiges verändert wie hast du dich
darauf vorbereitet klar also wir sind
jetzt in einem tropischen Gebiet
irgendwie auf einem Ozean nicht mehr in
Schweden ist komplett was anderes Thema
ja wir haben auch Regenzeit dann
Luftfeuchtigkeit Vize Zeug groß drauf
vorbereitet auf die Geschichte habe ich
mich nicht also weil ich war schon ein
paar mal den Tropen und weiß ungefähr
wie es ist klar man guckt hier und da
ein paar Techniken an wie man jetzt
vielleicht ein Moskitos fernhalten kann
und so weiter aber ich habe generell
mich auf das ganze schon vorbereitet mit
verschiedenen Videos Büchern aber jetzt
nicht
ultra Spitze auf so Kleinigkeiten im
gesamten eine weitere große Änderung war
der drop off der deutlich extremer
geworden ist wie war der Tag für dich
also der drop of day ging für mich
eigentlich schon einen Abend vorher los
wo wir die Handys abgeben mussten und
ein paar Stunden davor habe ich mich
noch mal mein Hotelzimmer gesetzt und
eine Playlist angehört die ich mir
vorbereitet habe auf den Hinflug und ein
paar Tage davor die mich so ein bisschen
die Stimmung gebracht haben das sind
mehr so vikingsmusik äh die mich
eingestimmt haben und ja da war die
handyabgabe und am nächsten Morgen
tatsächlich wir hatten ja auch dann
keine Uhr aber wir war schon klar das
recht früh losgeht habe ich ja noch mal
eine kleine Aufmerksamkeit
Meditationsübung gemacht wo ich
verschiedenste Sinne aktiviere im Sinne
von schmecken fühlen riechen hören und
mich irgendwie noch mal voll Fokus
darauf zu ja zu funktionieren was jetzt
kommt und dann gegen die Heli drop of
action los und die war krank das war
also als wir dann da stand auf dem
Rollfeld eingehakt knossi noch mal diese
Ansage gemacht haben als kostet immer
die Ansage gemacht hat wo wieder
eingehakt waren dann in die Helis keine
Türen drin es geht hoch Heelys
über die Insel das war ein
unbeschreibliches Gefühl dann zu sehen
wie der erste rausspringt die Helis
drumrum Kreisen Du realisierst erstmal
es geht los es war völlig irre völlig
irre
bis ich dann an meinem Spot ankam ich
weiß nicht ob ich da jetzt auch schon
auf eingehen soll
vor mir und das habe ich ja noch
mitbekommen
wurden knossi Nova und Auto
rausgeschmissen und jedes Mal habe ich
natürlich sofort Sports begutachtet ah
Palm dichter Dschungel wo kann man hin
äh wie sieht das aus immer schon
glücklich gesagt guck mal hier geil und
dann flogen wir zu dem Sport von Auto
war nur noch Auto und ich im Helikopter
und wir kommen so an sein Spot nicht
immer so mega es ist schon sechs sieben
Palm ich Klatsch Auto ab und sagst Du
geil sexy ein mega kannst ne und äh
freue mich richtig für ihn feiern so ein
paar Mal Proben gesehen dachte ja kann
er reingehen er springt raus mit
irgendwie dem hier rückwärts mega ich
alleine drin wir fliegen und fliegen
aber ganz schön lange so eine geile
Bucht fliegen wir wieder mal vorbei
und dann sagt irgendwie ich glaube Maxi
mir so ja das ist deine Bucht
und ich gucke in diese ich gucke diese
Wucht rein damit ich mich verarschen ich
gucke da rein das war ein dreckiger
schlammiger
spitz zulaufender Pfeil mit einer
einzigen riesig großen Kokosnuss Palme
wo ich schon aus dem Helikopter gesehen
habe diese 20 Meter hoch waren wo ich
mir dachte so ihr wollt mich doch
komplett verarschen ihr wollt mich ich
komme mich um keine Palme nirgendwo nur
steigen sechs sieben Meter hoch und dann
hieß komm raus raus und let's go und
dann ja
das Spiel sein Lauf ihr wurdet
ausgesetzt wir als Team machen es uns in
der Hacienda gemütlich und an Tag 3
fängt es an richtig zu scheppern wie
hast du das erste dicke Gewitter
wahrgenommen ja Tag drei das erste
truppengewitter es hatte davor die Tage
immer schon so ein bisschen genieselt
aber das okay und dann habe ich gemerkt
okay es fängt an zu regnen es wird immer
mehr ich hatte zu dem Zeitpunkt zum
Glück schon entscheide aufgebaut auch
mit dem Regendach und so weiter und es
war glaube ich so tagsüber und ich hatte
so ein ganz kleinen Mini Erd fails
Vorsprung wo ich dachte okay ich halte
mich erstmal ein bisschen sicher habe
mich da das beobachtet es schüttet
wirklich aus Eimern ich sofort in den
Gedanken jetzt saufen alle ab ich mich
richtig gefreut richtig Hype und dachte
so
ich gehe duschen habe mich in diesem
Feld Ding nackt ausgezogen meine ganzen
Sachen die noch halbwegs Trockner
untersucht sind verstaut bin raus habe
da hier bin gesprungen abgeklatscht habe
den Fehler gemacht habe mich übrigens
gefreut so und dann so nach einer halben
Stunde so
gut es schüttet halt jetzt immer noch
damit ich da weiter nackt rumspaziert
nach einer Stunde merk ich so gut
scheiße jetzt wird mir kalt dann habe
ich irgendwann mich dazu entschieden ja
mist ich muss den Kram wieder anziehen
weil ich fange gerade übel an zu frieren
und ist verändert sich nicht sondern es
regnet seit einer Stunde anderthalb dann
habe ich mich wieder angezogen habe ich
dahin gehockt habe ich folgen lassen und
habe dann aber erstmal so realisiert ja
das war heute noch lustig aber das kann
auch ganz schön mies werden so also das
erste Gewitter war noch so gesagt hat
man richtig gut okay das erste Gewitter
war für dich noch ziemlich entspannt wie
ging es dann aber für dich weiter weil
in den nächsten Tagen hat es ja quasi
nonstop ordentlich geknallt also ich
muss sagen so ein Gewitter wieder habe
ich noch nie erlebt
und das hat es ja mehrfach aufgebaut und
die das habt ihr wahrscheinlich gar
nicht mitbekommen aber aus meinem
shelter in der ersten und zweiten Nacht
habe ich in der Ferne die ganze Zeit
Gewitter gesehen es hat die ganze Zeit
geblitzt aber es hat nicht geregelt ich
habe nichts gehört muss also auf dem
Ozean gewesen sein und dann wenn man
keine unter vier ungefähr kam halt und
das erste richtige Ding wo es geknallt
hat und es kam immer näher und ich weiß
noch dass der Himmel halt immer
aufgeblitzt hat dann kann der Donner
dann kann man die Regel okay du musst
zählen habe ich auch kommentiert den
Kamera wie weit weg und dann noch so ja
fünf
entspannt weit weg und plötzlich macht
ist nicht ein Blitz sondern so vier
und wirklich eine Sekunde nach
ich merkte mein mein Brust richtig wenn
beim Brust verdrückte sich irgendwie ein
mein Oberkörper durch die Vibration mir
war ja klar dass donnern ist nicht das
Schlimme wenn ich den Blitz sehe und
überlebt habe ja dann kann ich dann kann
nichts passieren ja dann lade ich da und
dachte mir so
das ist scheiße jetzt egal dann habe ich
mir so vorgestellt ich glaube Leute die
das so ein paar Sachen dazu nicht wissen
mit den abstellen dass der doch nicht
das schlimme ist sondern der Blitz und
so weiter die das einschätzen können die
scheißen sich gerade richtig ein und
irgendwo auf dieser Insel werden andere
Teilnehmer von mir sitzen und gerade
richtig Panik haben irgendwie fand ich
jetzt aber schon wieder geil so jetzt
ein bisschen dumm ich weiß ja natürlich
immer mit der Prämisse dass keinem was
passiert aber ja also das das reine
Blitz und Donnern habe ich schon
irgendwie gefeiert aber diese extreme
stark kriegen führte halt dazu dass
immer alles komplett nass war und ich
habe mir ein Shelter gebaut oder mehrere
das der alles schon gesehen
wahrscheinlich
die waren immer so zu 90 bis 95% dicht
ich habe die wirklich Imbiss ins Detail
ausgearbeitet aber irgendwo kam dann
doch mal Tropfen durch das Problem ist
wenn halt so fünf Tropfen durchkommen
und das aber über vier Stunden dann bist
du auch nass so dass egal wo ich war
nach jedem Gewitter komplett
durchgeweicht war nicht gleich nach 5
Minuten aber dann immer mittendrin und
dann kann das Problem ich war irgendwann
nach einer gewissen Zeit angemessen aber
mir wurde kalt weil ich mich nicht
bewegt habe deswegen habe ich mich dazu
entschieden rauszugehen aus meinem
Shelter mich wirklich voll Ringen zu
lassen das macht doch keinen großen
Unterschied dass ich mich bewege um
wenigstens Körperwärme zu produzieren
und dann bin ich teilweise Gewitter
gegangen spaziert ja okay super dass das
Gewitter keinen riesen Problem für dich
war was war aber in dieser Staffel dein
größtes Problem das waren zwei Sachen
das war einmal das Vize Zeug ähm ich bin
gespannt wie es bei anderen war bei mir
was wirklich die absolute es war die
ganze Zeit da äh Mücken und diese
Sandfliegen ich habe mich teilweise
komplett mit Schlamm eingeschmiert alles
dicht gemacht ich habe mir immer meine
Unterhose die wirklich nach Obdachlosen
Bahnhof Toilette immer und hat nach
vielen Tagen ins Gesicht gezogen um
irgendwie nicht gestochen zu werden habe
ich keine Luft dadurch bekommen es war
wirklich eine Katastrophe ich habe mich
einfach immer nur noch stechen lassen
oder halt wieder mit Schlamm eingerieben
Viehzeug war wirklich ein riesen
Riesenproblem und ich war sieben Tage
lang nass also es gab glaube ich am
sechsten Tag einmal einen schönen Tag da
habe ich alles halbwegs trocken bekommen
bis auf die Schuhe die waren immer nass
7 Tage lang
ja hier schon später das war alles
wieder das war es nass also das ich war
einfach klitschnass und so sah meine
Füße meine Haut meine Hände alles aus
hoffentlich hast du aber nicht nur
Probleme gehabt was nimmst du Positives
aus der zweiten Staffel von Seven vs
wild mit das Positive was ich für mich
mitnehme
ist einmal ganz klar das Thema
Dankbarkeit so im generellen für ein
Dach im Kopf für eine Wohnung für einen
vollen Kühlschrank für Gesundheit und
sowas ähm im Allgemeinen für mich
persönlich habe ich aber einen Punkt
ganz klar mitgenommen und das ist dieses
ähm nicht kaputt zu gehen sondern immer
versuchen durchzubeißen zu kämpfen immer
einfach nicht aufzugeben so und egal wie
scheiße die Situation ist er muss dazu
sagen ich hatte auch am Tag fünf halt
Magen-Darm ich habe Durchfall und keine
Ahnung was hatte Magenkrämpfe stand
irgendwie da völlig verkrampft da war so
das einmal wo ich wirklich daran dachte
wenn das jetzt über mehrere Tage anhält
und das noch schlimmer wird dann habe
ich echt ein Problem
aber ansonsten ist es einfach diese
diese mentale Kraft zu sagen hey 90
Prozent passiert hier oben ich bin hier
sieben Tage lang draußen ich habe eine
[ __ ] verrostete Machete so und damit
mache ich hier alles und damit komme ich
einfach 7 Tage durch und wenn ich das
geschafft habe
klar gibt Sachen die krasse sind ohne
Frage aber dann sind viele Sachen im
Alltag wo du sagst sah alles Kinderkacke
sehr schön du hast schon angesprochen
für dich und Otto gab es in dieser
Staffel nur einen Gegenstand die Machete
wenn du dir in der Mitte der Woche einen
Gegenstand hättest dabei wünschen können
welcher wäre es gewesen und warum zwei
Sachen fallen mir ein das ist entweder
Moskitonetz oder Feuerstahl
aus dem Bauhaus würde ich fast sagen
feuersteiber mit der damit kann ich noch
ein bisschen mehr machen ich kann zum
einen nasse Kleidung an bewölkten Tagen
trocknen und ich kann damit mit alten
moskitonestern Rauch machen oder
generell auch machen um dieses Feature
zu vertreiben somit hätte ich meine
beiden Probleme bekämpfen können mit
einem kleinen Feuerstahl das hätte
werden riesengamechanger gewesen auf
jeden Fall würdest du deinen besten
Freundin so eine Erfahrung mal wünschen
oder Ihnen dazu raten du musst schon
ganz schön bescheuert im Kopf sein wenn
du das freiwillig machst so es ist im
Nachhinein Erfahrung über dich sehr sehr
dankbar bin aber in der Situation ist es
größtenteil sie absolute Hölle und du
sagst warum mache ich diesen Scheiß hier
einfach nur durchziehen durchhalten
irgendwie durch den Tag kommen irgendwie
die Probleme versuchen zu lösen und dann
bist du oft in Situationen du hast die
Probleme gelöst du hast etwas trocken
bekommen ich habe
aber ausgeholt Technik entwickelt dass
ich gemerkt habe dass mein Shirt am
Körper trocknet ich brauche nichts
anderes außer es darf nicht regnen und
mein Shirt trocknet dann habe ich
angefangen meine Socken zu nehmen und
die in dein Hemd zu reiben um die
Feuchtigkeit von meiner Socke in mein
Hemd zu transferieren und dann mit dem
Körper das Hemd wieder zu trocknen aber
das trocken wieder mit der Socke solche
Techniken habe ich probierte irgendwie
was Song zu kriegen dann machst du das
über drei vier Stunden hast ein Ergebnis
vier Stunden alles nass und dann nix
auch so irgendwann Akzeptanz ja ich bin
das ich stelle mich jetzt auf ein sieben
Tage lang
nasse sein sieben Tage lang verstecken
zu lassen 7 Tage lang kein Feuer
anzukriegen weil alles nasses
Durchblutung reden 7 Tage lang eine
dreiviertel Kokosnuss zu essen und den
Scheiß durchzustehen hast du in der
Woche irgendwann mal ernsthaft daran
gedacht abzubrechen den Knopf zu drücken
und dich abholen zu lassen der Gedanke
aufzugeben es gab zwei Punkte in der
ganzen Geschichte es war einmal ein Tag
zwei das war aber kein Punkt des
Aufgebens aber es war schon einen mental
Break wo ich realisiert habe das was ich
mir im internet vorher angeguckt habe an
coolen anderen survival Videos wie sich
also vorbereiten und machen mit anderen
traumständen mit Kokosnuss Palmen und
Bambus und fischbär das ist es hier
gerade nicht ich bin im kompletten
abfucker gelandet ich bin in einer
kompletten Deponie in Müll im Schlamm
Urwald gelandet so das war so ein
Realisation ein Tag zwei wo ich gemacht
habe okay ich muss irgendwie Umdenken
aber da war nie der Punkt dass ich
abbreche
der Gedanke abbrechen zu müssen war
wirklich ein Tag fünf wo der
Magen-Darm-Infekt losging und ich
plötzlich nachts aufstehe und Durchfall
habe und dachte okay scheiße ich noch
mal nachts noch mal und das über den
ganzen Tag so gegen mehrfach und ich
dachte okay ich krieg nicht raus woran
es liegt und ich muss eine Lösung dafür
wenn ich das nicht hinkriege und das
über zwei drei Tage enthält dann muss
ich rausweichen das war der einzige
Punkt wo ich überlegt habe das ist dazu
führen könnte wenn es sich verschlimmert
wunderbar vielen Dank fürs Interview
herzlichen Glückwunsch zu sieben
geschafften Tagen und viel Spaß zurück
in der Zivilisation fertig
[Musik]